sommes avec morad el hattab écrivain
auteur de saïf al islam kadhafi un rêve
d'avenir pour la libye aux éditions et
bonnier bonsoir morad el hattab merci
d'être avec nous alors cette annonce
sein des forces du gouvernement libyen
d'union nationale est ce qu'on peut dire
quelle marque un tournant décisif dans
la lutte contre le maréchal haftar au
nullement vous pourrez très interview il
s'arrache qui est moins lui et qui parle
au nom du peuple libyen présideront de
ses forces
puisque vous savez comme moi par rapport
aux informations qui nous arrive que ce
sont des prises temporaires qui sont
obtenues grâce à la venue sur le terrain
de milice islamiste de la turkish venir
depuis la série et d'ici peu je pense
que les forces vont se rééquilibrer et
la vraie question que je me pose chaque
jour c'est où sont les navires de
l'opération navale européenne
irini qui ont justement pour fonction de
faire respecter l'embargo sur les armes
imposé par les hôteliers à la libye et
d'en assurer la surveillance et qui va
chaque jour devant le passé des bateaux
turcs empli de djallit vous vous posez
la question c'est peut-être que vous
avez un début de réponse
j'apprécie votre pertinence
effectivement je crois que le cir de gan
qui en réalité à la tête du gouvernement
de sa rage puisque nous c'est sa rage ne
tient qu'une marionnette il a vendu
entre guillemets les étoiles les eaux
territoriales libyennes à la turquie
donc je vous dis que c'est que le début
d'une prémisse d'une guerre bien plus
large qui va s'ouvrir puisque des pays
tiers qui ne s'annonce pas aujourd'hui
vont intervenir en l'occurrence grèce
chypre israël egypte par rapport à ces
pièces sont aux territoriales erdogan
essaie de refaire des légumes une
province ottomane
vous imaginez bien ne sera pas du goût
de tout le monde et aussi de l'europe
mais n'oubliez pas un détail c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les états unis
dit rien on ne peut pas croire qu'ils ne
sont rien aujourd'hui 12 andré l'espoir
il ya notamment la reprise des
négociations avec l'onu trêve entre
défense n'y croyais pas du tout l'onu ou
non parce que le livre serait comme moi
à tirer j'ai réussi à nommer seguin
salamé qui a abandonné tellement c'était
un inextricable et lui avait fait le
choix de demy recommandé de garantir
l'autorité que mon parti qui est elle sa
rage donc de toute façon aujourd'hui ne
peut plus rien faire tout ça va se gérer
par rapport à des puissances étrangères
en l'occurrence on sait qu'aujourd'hui
de manière ouverte il s'agit de la
turquie et de la russie et en
arrière-plan les émirats l'egypte
l'arabie saoudite le qatar est que dans
un avenir très proche tout le monde sait
que le seul à même d'amener mon cohésion
nationale
et s'ils sont kadhafi ne pas voir
remettre en contact avec beaucoup de ses
proches qu aujourd'hui au niveau des
peuples bien qu'on interroge jamais
désarmant c'est le seul espoir et allez
savoir
moi je crois franchement d'asta les purs
possession force graal et qui est
effectivement il risque de sortir un
maintien un homme un homme providentiel
voilà il est de plus en plus isolé pour
vous le maréchalat star parce qu'on l'a
présenté comme subissant une suite de
revers mais tous les analystes ne
semblent pas croire justement à cette
version
mais moi je vous dis que le général
after he gagnera la partie puisque il
est hors de question
oubliez jamais l'arrière fond je sa rage
n'est que le pantin d'erdogan
il imaginait bien dans la région toute
cette masse de jazz sont arrivés sur
place cause de gros problèmes de
sécurité en opérant de l'algérie pour le
sahel est aujourd'hui même si j'ai
trouvé assez bizarre étrange la position
de mon pays la france on a le drian nous
tenons des affaires étrangères qui
appelle à page 2 dans le même temps le
lecteur de la descente
soutien sans dire à part donc il a
d'abord carton est redessiné à star va
reprendre effectivement la partie mais
ce qu'on fait de jouer un homme
providentiel
parce que le peuple libyen est fatigué
et ne soutient aucun des protagonistes
et à choisir c'est vrai que pour
l'instant il faut être honnête c'est
plus de côté la star merci morad el
hattab écrivain auteur de saïf al islam
kadhafi nous avoir apporté votre analyse
ce soir merci à vous